what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so picking up with the epilogue of
super Suns rebirth this is it's really
fun I mean dude I love the whole idea of
like super suns of tomorrow when I love
the Teen Titans and the super Suns
comics it's so fun this is one of the
things I really enjoyed I was never like
a huge reader of Teen Titans I mean I
watch the show back in the day but I was
never like an avid Teen Titans fan and
so for a lot of people who have been
like who've been reading Teen Titans for
years I'm sure for a lot of you guys
this is just like yeah this isn't
anything I haven't seen before I love it
but I've seen all this before but to me
is brand-new this is all basically new
stuff to me and I love this whole thing
I especially love the character of
Jonathan Kent Jonathan Kent is
definitely my favorite character in DC
rebirth like it's it's it's just it's
amazing how hilarious he is because he's
just like a teen he has fun I kind of
stuff but again this is a really really
important moment because remember in the
last video we had talked about how Tim
Drake had come from the future as a
byproduct of the fact that somewhere
along the line Jonathan Kent Superman's
son would essentially develop his
father's who are really you know
Superman solar flare power basically
allowing him to kind of discharge this
massive amount of solar energy due to
the fact that Damian Wayne would betray
him at some point so as a result when he
discharges all the solar energy it would
wipe out the city of Metropolis it would
kill like a million people and then in
turn a Superboy would just kind of
become like you know this character's
everybody see everybody's looking
forward to kind of try to track down but
the whole idea of Tim Drake was to find
a way to go back into the past and stop
it from happening so it's pretty cool
for what it was because this version of
Tim really became a much darker version
of the character that he is now but the
fact remains here that when the kind of
climax to the super suns of tomorrow's
story happened and Jonathan Kent began
to kind of emanate this solar flare
power essentially Tim Drake absorbed
that energy and was then thrown into the
timestream and this is huge because
again this is one of those instances
when DC gives us like these little
flashbacks to basically tell us here are
the things that have happened and here
are the things that haven't happened so
for example I mean you see from like
this opening the slow burning page here
you know this giant splash page that
things like crisis on Infinite Earths
happen things like you know Infinite
Crisis superboy-prime that happened but
also DC Universe rebirth number one the
events of forever evil those things took
place - now again what I'm really
expecting from DC to kind of sidetrack
here for a second but what I'm really
expecting from DC is to give us this
kind of zero hour crisis and time event
which is to say we might necessarily get
a crisis but once the whole rebirth
thing is basically done which is
say when we get an explanation of like
what dr. Manhattan did and how his
actions impacted and changed everything
that it'll eventually segue into DC most
likely giving us like a timeline like
basically here are all the things that
have happened that are in continuity
like that's kind of what I expect to
take place but the fact remains here
that at this point Tim Drake this future
version of Tim Drake is in the
timestream so basically he could be
anywhere and at any point in time we
have no idea where he is
he could end up at any point from the
events of crisis on Infinite Earths all
the way up to the modern day so who
knows when he would pop up and it's cool
because it allows DC to really offer
even if they wanted to like an ongoing
series or miniseries or something like
that where this future version of Tim
Drake is our to ease our tour guide for
the multiverse so really for like the
entire timeline of DC Comics there's a
lot of stuff that you can do the other
half of this is something that kind of
calmly by surprise with this aftermath
is epilogue is that we basically have
the Titans of tomorrow meeting the new
superheroes meaning the existing
superheroes you know the current of
Superman and you know the Teen Titans
and so on Superman doesn't know who they
are and that's kind of the interesting
thing remember this on the surface our
initial response if we've forgotten a
couple of things our initial response
would be but they should know each other
like this they should definitely
definitely know who the other is and so
again I want to take this this this bit
of a second this little you know a
little bit of an opportunity I want to
talk about Superman for a second a lot
of people are still a little bit
confused about Superman reborn their
route is kind of confused about how that
works and how the new Superman's origin
story works and all that kind of good
stuff so to offer an explanation here
let's take DC rebirth when DC rebirth
kicked off which is to say the release
of DC Universe rebirth number one we had
two supermen in the main DC Universe
we had the Superman that arose during
the events of you know the new 52
basically when DC rebooted and said we
wanted you guys who I guess to treat
superheroes like we've never published
them before we had this new younger
version of Superman and then we had the
classic Superman and the whole idea with
this is that it was DC basically saying
hey look you know somebody did something
somebody messed with things now because
of what's happened in DC rebirth so far
what we can kind of presume here and
again you know it's it's still a little
bit fuzzy in terms of how it works what
we kind of resume here is that when
flashpoint happened and you know Barry
Allen went back in time you know save
his mom's life and then went back in
time and let her die after realizing how
bad everything got and so on and so
forth dr. Manhattan stepped in and
messed with things
presumably he made the new Superman
whatever the case may be but the reason
here is that we ended up having this
quote unquote new universe that existed
and then you had classic Superman who
basically left his universe and arrived
in this one and so that's how we had
those two supermen there we basically
had two versions of the same character
who were just from two different
universes more or less two different
points in time and the result was that
with Superman reborn it was basically
taking those two versions of Superman
bringing them together and then just
erasing the entire history of the
individual characters and so as it
stands right now with this version of
Superman that we see here this one in
this story right now and the one that
we've seen after the events of Superman
reborn basically there is no classic
Superman in the sense of like the death
of Superman all those old stories
there's also no new 52 Superman what
there is is there is this Superman and
then whatever parts of his past DC wants
to keep intact so we know that this
version died back in 1992 you know and
in death the Superman that happened he
was killed by doomsday
we know that those kind of events to
have taken place and the new origin was
given to us as part of the aftermath of
Superman reborn so again that's kind of
what this version is supposed to be and
in terms of the role he plays he's
basically classic Superman but in terms
of you know this being an exact copy not
necessarily the case that classic
Superman that we're familiar with that
one's basically gone and this is kind of
like a merged version of the two
characters hopefully that makes sense to
you guys I don't really know how to
explain it any clearer than that so I
don't know I you might have to kind of
investigate outside of my videos in
order to find a way that's more
conducive to your ability to understand
it but the fact remains here it is kind
of cool because again this is why this
version of Superman
doesn't know these Titans now if
Superman reborn never happened and the
new 52 Superman died and the classic
Superman was here and his origin story
was never rewritten he would definitely
know these characters he would say yeah
Conner Kent
I remember you how come you don't
remember me you're basically a clone
version of me from when I died and Lex
Luthor made you how come you don't
remember me with Bart Allen it would be
like yeah I remember you but you're the
grandson of Barry Allen you were brought
to the 20th century because your powers
were out of control and then you know
Wally West and a handful of others
managed to find a way to keep him in
check and basically set you back - no I
remember your whole past I remember you
when you were this tall like I mean I I
I imagine that's how Superman would
respond but again he doesn't necessarily
have all the same memories but we would
kind of expect him to you know to a
degree but again that's why it's so so
interesting and that's why it's so
intriguing is because DC is very much
playing it by ear now even then with
like the the character of beast boy his
initial response is well
I feel like I know that girl cassie
sandsmark like i feel like we've met
before and this is really kind of like
BC hitting home with the idea that maybe
there is a connection here that if dr.
Manhattan stepped in and modified
everybody's memories and changed
everything around and move these pieces
around the board in order to make it
look different than it actually was then
maybe this effect is starting to wear
off but again we can't really take that
by just like one phrase by one sentence
from Beast Boy we can't really ride that
as an absolute certainty at this point
it's just kind of like haphazard
guessing no the other funny thing about
this is it's kid flash I love kid flash
love kid flash she's almost as awesome
as Jonathan Kent and the funny thing
about this is that where everybody's
kind of talking about the aftermath and
the Titans of tomorrow and whether or
not they should ask about the future and
if they should get answers and different
things like that kid flashes whole
responses hey I got something better
than anything we could have gotten and
when people are like what he's like a
selfie which is amazing because it's so
easy to forget in this story that they
are teenagers I mean they're just young
kids you know their kids just kind of
having a great time being superhero is
also dealing with teenage issues Raven
gets pissed off and destroys the phone
it is pretty funny you know these these
these little interactions things like
that but the other half of this is that
this basically picks up with the whole
idea of Superman addressing the issue of
Damien and Jonathan Kent because
Superboy effectively sits down and says
okay the whole reason Tim Drake came
here is because some point along the
line Damian you're gonna betray my son
and when you do he's gonna lose his mind
and he's gonna destroy metropolis so you
guys can't be friends anymore
you guys can't hang out and it's kind of
interesting this is actually a really
interesting scenario this is the perils
of time travel this is the danger of
time travel we don't have an answer to
the question of if Superman lets them
stay friends is that what leads to the
conflict or Superman refuses to let them
conflict we don't know we don't have an
answer to that we don't know which one
of these paths leads to this massive
calamity maybe they both do I mean sure
you know there's an argument to be made
well you know things have changed just
by virtue of 10 Drake going into the
past and you know encountering them and
trying to stop them but it doesn't mean
that that it's not going to happen it
could very well just happen by a
different means a circumstance could
unfold in a similar way just under
something a little bit different you
know different conditions but the whole
event remains maybe it's Gotham City
that Jonathan blows up instead of
metropolis that's the cool thing about
this and that's why this is interesting
because it does leave the question out
there has the entire conflict been
prevented now before his offence
Dameon steps up and this is this is a
cool thing this is why Jonathan as a
character has such a great impact on
Damien for those people who have been
reading DC Comics for quite some time
really you know with like a son of the
demon going all the way back to the
introduction of Damian Wayne his
characters evolved a lot over the years
when he first showed up in fact he
pissed off a lot of Batman fans when he
first showed up he was just this really
entitled spoiled kid who believed the
world revolved around him it was his way
or the wrong way and that's really how
his character was initially now over the
years as different riders have evolved
his character he's grown the way that
you would expect him to a lot of this
has been a byproduct of Batman stepping
in and Batman basically saying look our
job is to protect people our job is not
to kill people who do bad things that's
the easy way out I mean there's been a
lot of work that's been done on behalf
of like Batman's character to kind of
flesh out Damian Wayne but in terms of
like him being more of a brighter spot
and kind of growing up and realizing
he's not the center of the universe a
lot of that comes from Jonathan Kent
because Jonathan Kent's kind of like
this immutable force of happiness that
exists it's why I'd love his character
so much because he's just a fun
character to read about and so that's
why him and Damian Wayne get along so
well because it's almost like yin and
yang it's like oil and vinegar it's
light and dark it's this cool thing
where these two characters who you would
never expect to be friends just
immediately hit it off and they have an
amazing friendship but in a lot of ways
whether Damian realizes it or not
Jonathan Kent helps to impact him and
make him a better person the other half
of this is remember despite the fact
that Damian Wayne does have a checkered
past and even though he does you know
has done some pretty shady things he is
an honorable guy and so in his mind it
is basically look Jonathan's not just a
potential member of the Teen Titans he's
not just a person that I've gone on
adventures with he's a friend and where
I come from friends watch their friends
backs that's very important that's a
very significant thing when it comes to
his character because it really hits of
the evolution of Damian Wayne as he's
grown over the years and so that's why
it's so cool so what they end up doing
is basically calling a vote and it's
actually really funny because they're
teleported to the Justice League
Watchtower by Superman and like their
initial responses like dude we're in the
Justice League Watchtower man like it's
really funny like they're sitting down
at like the big superheros chairs and
it's funny cuz it's like man like we're
do we get to sit at the adult table it's
really really interesting and it's
really intriguing because this again
hits home at the idea that they're
teenagers they're having fun then you
if it's what's so cool about that is
that's why I love the Teen Titans so
much now of course Damien's response is
okay we basically got to call this to a
vote and Damian's in the corner of
Jonathan Kent he's like look let's make
up a partial Titan at the very least now
even if it's only one of those
circumstances where Damian's like look
we got to keep an eye on Jonathan Kent
just to make sure he doesn't lose his
mind it is cool because he is basically
voting for Jonathan to be rolled in when
Damien was staunchly against it
initially his little stance was you're
not a teenager you're a preteen you're
not old enough to be on the Teen Titans
now of course this also sees the arrival
of Batman you know after having come to
you more or less after being defeated by
it by Tim Drake kind of knocked
unconscious and he basically says okay
let's take a vote and the result is that
you know everybody's kind of like no
we're not really in favor of Jonathan
Kent joining the Teen Titans now it's
not because they hate Jonathan right I
mean there may be a little bit of fear
there may be a little bit of concern but
the bigger idea here is that when Tim
Drake showed up Tim Drake dismantled the
the Teen Titans so fast and so easily
now keep in mind Batman incorporated way
back before the new video I guess really
the Batman incorporated when new 52 was
launched that basically confirmed that
Tim Drake is probably the world's best
detective second only to Bruce Wayne
that he's beyond do Damian Wayne he's
beyond Dick Grayson he's beyond odd
Jason Todd in terms of his detective
abilities he's just below Bruce Wayne
and so it's not like they went against
the Joker and the Joker just dismantled
them you know work the Riddler who
tricked them you know it's one of the
the best detectives out there who knows
all their strengths and weaknesses
because he came from the future but it
is cool because what this means is that
the Teen Titans were effectively
fighting a villain that could predict
all their moves before they made them
and so in order to basically be that
much better they have to be
quote-unquote unpredictable which is to
say they have to have a better
understanding of each other they have to
know what all their strengths of
weaknesses are now this is not
accidental it's not like DC put this in
there just for the sake of just having
it in there way back in when the Justice
League was first launched back in 1960
one of the first things that Justice
League did in order to instill trust in
each member of the team was to reveal
their identities to each other do
basically say like here's here's our
secret identities
you know I bruise I Batman and Bruce
Wayne neo I Superman and Clark Kent I
Wonder Woman em Diana Prince I the flash
and Barry Allen it was cool to see that
kind of thing because it instilled trust
now this is why this is done it's a
homage to the old school Justice League
story but it's designed to hit home at
the idea but the only way to really know
someone is to let your guard down is to
basically say okay
my cards are on the table I'm not
holding anything back they might accept
you they might reject you but you have
no regrets under the circumstances and
that's what the ton of the team Titans
have to do they got to throw their cards
out there they got to just spill out
their strengths their weaknesses their
fears their hopes and desires and make
themselves stronger as a team so that
instead of viewing each other as just
people who fight alongside other people
they view themselves as a family as
they're invested in each other because
they find a common connectivity they
find a common theme something that
unites them under a singular banner and
until they're able to do that on their
own there's no room for new additions
and so the result is that Jonathan Kent
is basically sit on the sidelines and
he's effectively not allowed into the
team Titans so again that's really how
this this epilogue ends and it's a great
it's a great epilogue to this whole
thing I love this story it's a great
little follow up great little aftermath
but if you guys are new here to comment
explain and make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]